you feel that you feel that atmosphere
damn welcome back everybody to Misha
part 2 I remember this place I wish I
didn't I don't know what to trust
writer books all right let's great are
we gonna start off this episode by
repeating May 1839 we start off with a
loading screen the other shilling share
him be on pinching African Sun has
continued to plague our expedition
making it impossible to dig until dusk
how professor Herbert managed to find
the location in these vast plains of
nothing there all from pressing our
mystery to me when I asked him about the
tomb again he told me about the legend
of tin Hunnam the mother of us all an
interesting story in its own right but I
can't help feeling there's more later
that evening
we uncovered a passage beneath the dunes
leading to a sand covered stones
structure the professor was confident it
was the tomb we sought and ordered the
others to clear the way late into the
dark cold night damn tomorrow I shall
lead the men into the ancient structure
hoping to reach the burial chamber no
matter what the professor is keeping
from me the dig should yield something
interesting to take back to London and
the British Museum
I don't remember any of this story this
is great tradition they can be
impossible to dig I'll professor Herbert
managed to find the location in these
vaults the paintings have nothing
amazing so we're playing on hard mode in
case you didn't know good all hard mode
it's brand new for amnesia in case you
were for some reason wondering why we're
playing amnesia again so it's it's
harder when you can't save the game as
often insanity will kill you you're a
total freakin bad axe if you play this
game this is fun to revisit will hemes
contract I hereby offer my full
attention and services to Alexander
Baron of brennenburg this contract will
reign for a total of three years when my
freedom shall return to me in addition
alexander baron of brandenburg is to
recommend my services at the persian
royal court and within the sanction of
the order of the black eagle may no man
break this seal will him house of
Garrick
we have to constantly be looking for
step looks like I'm having weird
interactions with a chair please chair
what are you doing thank you so much
what
the atmosphere it's so good huija blood
oh my god well with all that door was
not opened
[Music]
see I don't feel safe reading like this
I'll read like this 17th of May 1839 my
hands tremble as I write I feel a need
to document my tribulation for I fear
that my memory will fail me if I linger
today I took some men and ventured into
the dark ancient passage we uncovered a
torches burned faintly in the murky air
as we slowly made our way underground
the men were superstitious and fearful
they argued loudly and I felt their
strange language getting to me I
mustered my strength and yelled at them
to continue down the slips and broken
steps on an the crudely carved passage
confused me it looked much older than
the fourth century structure we had
expected the twisting path emerged into
a great antechamber the walls were lined
with statues unlike any I'd ever seen
despite their unearthly quality I felt a
strange familiarity toward them which
haunts me still at the far end of the
chamber a great slab of stone sealed off
would ever lay ahead I gave the order to
raise it and as I pushed through the
narrow space the heavy stone suddenly
dropped ceiling me inside I was trapped
when you had a bad day you take come on
down
I maybe they can make amnesia - in
Algeria you know what I mean what god
damn it man it's ridiculous any sound I
hear is gonna I know I think I remember
Hey yep mm oh my god stop smoking
yourself out you idiot
look hey stop
oh wait oh no I'm out of dammit all
right Oh God all right this is quick
quick quick quick quick quick
I don't think there's anything in here
let's not waste time
oh my sanity is dropping damn it I had
to stop wasting alright we're gonna do
this chair we're gonna you see the light
over there yes sir let's go
that's frickin actually you gotta go I
gotta go damn it I'm sorry I betrayed
you I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay we're fine what the hell what are
you doing are you trying to accomplish
I love her you can throw stuff I can see
the light hallelujah okay Oh
that was not human
happy the corner
oh I remember this hey hey hey
darlings no no no I'm not gonna draw Oh
was that not the puzzle
it's that later sorry I try to kill you
we're gonna have to use one just won't
go in here
so we're missing something what are we
missing
we I think we have to go where the with
that gentleman was making his wonderful
little noise you know I recorded I'm
Nisha I was still in university and I
hated it and my sleep schedule was just
completely off I would legit record this
game I would wake up randomly and like
3:00 a.m. and I would sit down and I
would record myself playing this and it
was like entering another round it was
like the most immersive experience I
both hated and loved it
trying to be conservative or yeah that's
bad that's real bad Oh what OH
all right we're fine no did I just die I
think I just died I think it's a sign no
I didn't die 39 after pounding the
unforgiving stone wall for what seemed
like an eternity and realized it was
hopeless I was trapped I fell to the
ground
gasping for air trying to focus that's
when I saw a faint shimmer my weakened
body was heavy to carry but I managed to
push myself toward the enchanting light
it was waiting for me it closed in dark
nothingness I felt myself drawn to the
mystic lightning
it's so appealing I'm like I'm off I
want it it's like a tight pod reached
out a reed in my hands the faint glow
escaped my fingers began to spark
brightly and spirit me away I'm looking
a lien memories of spiraling towers
endless deserts and impossible geometry
the next thing I cannot believe that one
is the grating sound of stone being
lifted the voices of the Arab pulling me
to safety grasped firmly in my hands was
the broken pieces I think most so that's
probably what curse name I don't
remember kingdom of Persia we're missing
something here how's our sanity head is
pounding hands are shaking not good not
good Felix okay and how do we make the
sanity go up again hasn't been attempted
to for centuries when the shadow arrives
it won't take long and two things start
falling apart
we're just buying time anyway let's do
what we can
there isn't much to be done and Wars we
should reinforce weak structures the
ground will tremble and there's a risk
everything will cave in on us especially
downstairs here here and there let's get
the servants working on it
well they weren't lying about hardmode
we're not doing too well
so I remember that was a puzzle here
that was kind of tricky or was it I
think literally I just throw this at it
[Applause]
still got a baby whoa dang I'm ass what
about my penis
what did I just do I [ __ ] broke it in
my hand that's pretty pretty weird you
have to be Swift
when you activate the first one you hear
that if it stops you'll have to start
over
is it all this a bit excessive you can
never be too careful with that I
remember this one
oh god this is our first interaction
with the son of a snake Oh God okay
let's just find them all first there's
one I think that fake
it's a note here ha Alstead of random ur
castle 1801 another region rich with
lore is outside deep within the east
persian woods for centuries there have
been stories surrounding the hamlet and
his neighbor Castle Brennan
that's so that's where we are the quiet
for Virginia's I know the quiet forest
glad mom's dress with scabbard Lake is a
picturesque as it can be obey it
the area is haunted by the dark and ask
any local and you will hear proof of the
widespread superstition all travelers
should indulge in themselves in such
conversation since it will certainly
serve as exciting entertainment all of
them have their own twist on the tales
but there are some motives that keep
reappearing the gatherers that's the
monster there the gatherer is that it I
don't know I don't remember this story
reached all the way back to the time of
the 30 years more it is said that
soldiers who abandoned their duty got
lost in the cold dog woods and we're
forever damned to roam the grounds their
bodies brought by they're tainted Souls
have left him disfigured and empty of
essence many have sight sighted them
over the years and described them as
horrid revenants they move silently
through the woods shying away from any
beholder they are called gatherers as
they seem to follow some ambition to
steal living creatures it is their prey
which can be heard struggling inside the
dam inside dam for a lab sacks dragged
behind them which reveal their presence
what dark scheme do they follow
oh so this is lure a visit sundown
Heinrich Cornelius Agrippa Agrippa that
we meet him later the well-known Airy
erudite visited all stat at the start of
the sixteenth century he reside in the
local inn for a fortnight as he looked
for remnants of kingdoms past during his
stay all the prominent members of
society paid notice and he is mentioned
in many records of the time one day he
went to investigate a borough in the
northwestern glades only to never be
seen again Heinrich is known to have
passed away in Brenham Grenoble's some
10 years later he dismissed the notion
of ever visiting all a site which makes
you wonder what really happened who was
this mysterious man who visited the
sleepy hamlet in the woods and what
happened to him and then finally the
important baked Baron sorry the Baron of
Brandenburg lives a reclusive life with
his family at his castle nearby all
stank and like most those of noble birth
rumors are inherited alongside with the
title researching the history reveals a
little before the castle was consumed by
fire in the late 16th century it was
rebuilt by Alexander a nobleman from the
Rhinelands claiming the role as
protector of the Persian State Alexander
helped the region to flourish and remain
popular throughout his presumed lifetime
the family but he's aligned the family
has always been secretly when it comes
to an image and heritage
therefore the birth and death of
Alexander and his offspring has never
been fully recorded this has fed the
idea that the Baron is in fact the one
and the same who came from the west over
300 years ago lived through the time of
occupation and joined the coveted order
of the black eagle
with the great leaders of this country
all right there's some lore for you a
lower nurse let's say let's do this
fricking puzzle I know not everyone
likes to notes but I'm playing this the
way I like it baby
that's right brows if you don't like it
you can go watch Marco there you go
there's only three of them
[Music]
I'm a genius boo so smart wine so now I
was staying in here now thank you
Oh close
he doesn't actually write
this is spooky it was just a spook and
was just a spook it was just a spook it
was just
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa why some monster did you guys see
that
don't let go that shield
I don't think I don't think you can
actually I'm going for
I'm going for I'm going for them go away
yeah oh yeah okay so I'm worried that
cuz I'm saved
I need a tinderbox
that's my Sandy I got a headache man hey
sucks
my heart is pounding I'm scared I love
it it has been so long you know when you
get into horror this is what you want I
think it's probably my fault as well a
lot of times I don't take games
seriously but I have so much respect for
this game at this point and its really
helping me immerse I love it this is a
bad place this is the this is the bad
place as soon as I find a tinderbox I'm
saving there's no God this is where the
bad is the bad place
I don't like this man I love you guys
you guys are awesome yeah yeah hello hey
brah
Oh God okay all right and you can refill
the oil he remember that all right why
did I do that
oh my god it was a reflex it just made
sense barrels you step my barrel don't
worry about don't worry Mouse I got your
ass
okay bass John well just get that back
and get that
Oh rod oh is this where you got a bill
like a bridge or something a bridge
Felix yes you are correct
yes I think you actually have to stack
these I'm not sure though is that really
that's kind of tricky isn't it
tinderbox yeah I love you tender box
yeah this is such a tiny box making my
weight this is such a half-life puzzle
isn't it I don't think this is it that's
a lot of climbing yeah yeah yeah you see
that that's as strong as it ever get
because you don't really have a weight
in this game this ain't it
what would I even do if I get up there
see right Mouse whoa okay that was it I
forgot it has a strong push feature I
don't think they use that in the mission
mods that's why I didn't remember it go
go away I don't like you
oh good good Oh you were yelling at me
to stop wasting the lantern okay well
that's not my problem is it [ __ ]
go away I should have I wasted I stupid
tinderbox stop running the what I don't
have time hello bad house there's bound
to be one of you who's hiding it get out
of my sight we're stop hiding the tip
who you prime that's not creepy at all
no it's me do I have everything I need I
had three of them I don't remember I
don't remember a [ __ ] Wow
I don't want to replay I don't want to
replay 40 minutes cuz I'm an idiot
okay it's not happening all right so
this we've been in and we've been in
here though
[Music]
all right I'm going I'm going
just like that I'm gone I'm gone good
pop I didn't go in there all right I'm
gone I'm gone I guess I'm gone I'm sure
I just guess I'm gone all right I'm gone
Finnick them finito Pepito
I need a same I need a same I need a
same I need to say come on guys come on
rise why did I waste that God forbidden
tinderbox so this is laboratory so yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right guys this
alright science no don't jump ah it's
fine it's just my leg it's broken it's
fine though I'll be going
no they're not are they what are you
talking be quiet be quiet you be quiet
everyone be quiet
alright wasting in attender boxes oh god
what do I do I need to make laboratory
happen where is the laboratory oh yeah I
just drop it god I forgot what I was
supposed to do damnit
oh I remember I remember dad remembers I
need a vial though I need for I need for
chemicals cool cool I was all I almost
got it Felix good job idiot
dumb schmuck you're a real dummy dawg
you're a real dummy dumb I'm a bomb a
bomb
I just need is that oil get out of my
sight this is my that yeah shame on you
you're all snakes yeah you're hiding
some from me you're hiding stuff I know
I know I your puzzle with us all right
fine you know what fine fine fine so we
need two more two more how you've done
this before
when you were ten times dumber ow ow
[Music]
where is a not playing games I should
have just a little soup in one afterward
where momentum yeah pour chemicals how
many do I have not enough
can we go in here now we can't okay guys
this is yep it's me when I eat too much
Taco Bell am i right my name is well
ahem house of Garrick these are my final
words my confession and testament two
years ago I was summoned to the castle
brennenburg as most of the errors error
aristocracy I was curious about what
happened about what this supposed knight
of the order who could want from me and
accept the imitation the Baron was
friendly and offered me a proposition it
dawned on me that the nature of the
contract was sordid and the reason and
that the reason I was chosen was because
of the follies of my past and not the
honors I had been rewarded with during
my time as a soldier I was to kidnap
healthy humans upon his slightest whim
and do so without asking questions in
return he would attest to my character
at the royal court advancing my
precision within the noble society I
would like to claim that I struggled
with my decision but it came but it came
swiftly and I accepted wholeheartedly
ever since the day I brought men women
and children to Brandenburg I can't
remember the number but there were many
ever since that day I brought men women
and children oh wait sorry
perhaps even a hundred none of whom were
ever seen or heard from again tonight
the Baron invited me and my men down to
the wine cellar to celebrate our work I
had my suspicions as we descended the
stairs but he insisted and joined us in
a toast the wine tasted fine and my man
drank without restraint so begins the
punishment for our sins the Baron has
locked us up and returned upstairs
forgive me for what I have done I was
weak and I fell into his diabolic ways
my men are screaming their skin have
been pierced by their own tangled bones
I feel my insides revolt against their
god-given nature blood has begun to pour
from my eyes and I can no longer Mary I
can't guys I legit okay
damn it though when we remember we're
missing one we're missing mine why is it
oh god the chains
and then you examine yourself again
what's the last one done this style last
oh let's say you speak Spanish what was
that
you're crazy Daniel your mouth go you
lost it go back to cuckoo town you down
the ball is it up there why do I keep
thinking it's up there it's not up there
[Music]
surely I'm missing something
I'm missing something should I say
should I say I feel like I should say no
I want to do this I want to freaking do
this come on how much I don't have oh
great
that's fine that's fine that's fine man
what could she mean with Gucci gain this
is a door I didn't see before hollowed
the world where were you before
oh god it's raining stones Latin Ataman
vouch
no like that huh put my sanity's going
hello okay we're fine we're fine we're
fine right we're fine right
never fine we're coochie-coochie a s
yeah literally this game oh we got a ha
ha ha
no no camp in the corner all right heads
pounding it's fine everyone has a
headache everyone's anyone all right
remember he will see you easier and you
haven't saved all right it's fine
hello excuse me sir are you perhaps one
of the gatherers
it's that good
why do I do that
try to find one fine fine she's got it
all right you've done this before Felix
we got this you got this come on you
ain't scared I ain't scared ain't scared
no reason to be scared
all right get fire it's the last bottle
the last are those
where is a duh or payments guys it's
been real it's been real but I'm freakin
a teehee Brown I realized okay let's go
- lets go - OH
[Music]
get yield on game ain't afraid of you
ain't afraid of no one okay this is the
lamb we're gonna we're gonna out don't
care don't care
Dino so virgin I don't care now science
right okay so
oh I need the vial as well I need a
stupid vial I don't have a pile right I
have this though bada bing botta boom
badda boom you get the green to get the
purple you get the orange
it's a powerful purple drank and I'm
wasting it on this I gotta activate the
valves is it a certain order I'm sure
it's fine
we just went green drank just pour the
acid down there
no all right on the door okay all right
we're gonna end that episode there thank
you guys so much
smash like if you enjoyed this episode
if you that would help out a lot
appreciate it
arigato gozaimasu I will see you guys
tomorrow with another episode I have to
pee really bad I'll see them
No
it's supposed to drink it or what
what am I supposed to do with it